Jeff Proctor sitting right here on the
Rich Eisen show good to see you Jeff
yeah great to see you rich now what did
you say your goal was to do listen to
what he says as soon as he sits down
yeah so I heard that you had a ride in
the two-seat Indy car with Mario
Andretti I did and that's really smooth
and you know a couple corners here and
there and so my proposal is to get you
out in the Honda Ridgeline race truck we
can go across some pretty serious
terrain and then a high rate of speed
and well could I get you to scream
scream a little scream a little bit now
who's driving this car you well I think
the first slap I'll Drive and then maybe
we'll pass the steering wheel over to
you now when you say passengers you're
not actually like detaching the steering
wheel well to get into the race truck
yeah you have to detach it now I'm the
type of guy that would be concerned that
it would come off while I was driving
what happens then
yeah well what happens then you're just
along for the ride it just along for the
ride so I mean we're looking at videos
right now of you doing exactly that now
would I go to the Baja Peninsula and do
it you know we can do it here locally
and okay the California desert how do
you get involved with this sort of thing
how do you get started in a career like
this Jeff yeah you know I think it all
started on two-wheel motorcycles you
know I did a lot of motocross racing as
a child and you know as you get older
and I have I have three great kids now
and you know they say that with age
comes caged and it kind of evolved from
two wheels to four wheels a little bit
safer form of off-road motor sports and
Here I am I was just one age age comes
caged would be and you were talking
about your three children in some way
shape or form that's correct because I
think around them somehow someway it's
cuz it is an incredible the Baja 1000
were you talking about like the LA what
is it like driving in the largest
spectator sports and that peninsula the
the point-to-point racing that's the
longest on planet Earth what's that like
yeah you know it's really hard to
describe the experience down there you
know we're up against the 50th
anniversary of the Baja 1000 that we're
heading to next week and you know Baja
is this really magical place it's it's
very difficult to describe what you can
expect in Baja when you're racing is
really the
unexpected we carry you know redundancy
of all of our parts and components of
the truck with us we're prepared to do
field repairs you know anything that it
takes to get us to the finish line this
year's race is 1,200 miles and you know
you see booby traps from the locals just
to create some excitement what do you
mean what are you talking to me
so typically you know the fans will be
out in the middle of nowhere it could be
the dark of night and we're cruising
along at race pace and all of a sudden
you'll see a campfire for those who
don't know race pace would be how fast
you know it depends but somewhere around
you'd say anywhere from 75 to 95 miles
an hour depending on the terrain okay
and you'll see a campfire pop up in the
middle of nowhere and that's usually our
sign to kind of check up a little bit
they can dig a trench why are they due
to create excitement they want to see a
crash they want to see some sort of you
know drama and so we have to be prepared
for these things I'll do the example
last race in June we were heading along
through a farmer's field and he had
rerouted his irrigation system into this
hole so we came up around a blind corner
and dropped right into this mud pit and
what happened sure enough field repairs
we we're stuck there's a crowd of people
gathered around and you know they want
to get up close and personal with the
race truck and sure enough the farmer
pulls up with his tractor at a tow rope
okay it's like okay well pay up and I'll
pull you out it was his it was his form
of revenue for the day ah interesting
yeah you know it sounds like to me cuz
you've got three young kids do you
reread the book my truck is stuck I have
that's what it sounds like right there
that you know had there been a ditch dug
for the Baja 1000 yeah but that sounds
strange to me because like think about
it if we're watching the World Series
and it's not exciting enough to watch
somebody steal a base that somebody gets
right there on Minute Maid in Houston
and digs an irrigation ditch right in
between first and second base I would
think that runs counter to actually you
know thanking the athletes for doing
it's just part of what we accept being
down in Baja and it's part of the
adventure so you don't mind it
you appreciate what it took the cap it's
something we accept yeah you know we
work to overcome all kinds of adversity
during the you know let's say anywhere
from 18 to 24 hours and during the race
Jeff Proctor here on the Rich Eisen show
so talk to me a little bit about your
your Honda Racing partnership and what
you're doing in specific with with this
race what are you doing yeah you know
it's kind of been an exciting
partnership it started out at SEMA in
2015 and really we we designed this race
truck to to launch the new 2016 Honda
Ridgeline and it was kind of used as a
concept vehicle with the plan to go
racing and now we're in our third season
racing the truck and it's you know we
feel like it's been well received and
just really value our partnership with
Honda and being able to promote this
truck I will tell you the race truck
doesn't have that really cool new truck
bed right of the engine so you could put
all your maybe field supplies inside the
bed lock it up just in case somebody's
coming with their tractor to try and do
something in the middle of the night
during the race I mean I'm just trying
I'm going through my mind about what the
ridge line has to try and set that thing
up does it have the Honda sensing
equipment to help keep me safe
absolutely it has all this want to make
sure safety equipment you need it you I
would trust behind the wheel me I don't
know not so much not so much what about
your families your family how does
somebody come and watch you do what
you're doing your kids just see what Dad
does and want to get in the truck
themselves you know so my nine-year-old
son you know he's active in the pits but
typically my other my seven and my
three-year-old they're a little too
young to be out there so they watch a
lot of dad's YouTube videos Isis and
that sort of thing keep some kind of
engaged with what I do and they spend
some time in the race shop with me and
that's fun for them yeah cuz you're a
first generation racer correct so this
would be you passing along to them what
really was not passed along to you yeah
exactly you know I I wasn't one of those
racers that grew up smelling race gas
and the pits no it was just something
that I developed a passion for and kind
of really pursued it well that's great
man
thanks for coming on this show good luck
to you when and all of your endeavors
with Honda Racing and usually when I
somebody says something like that I
accept be careful I might actually
accept and get into the ridge line we'll
make it happen for real yep okay and the
seat belts work and everything it's a
it's a five-point harness we'll put you
in a fire suit
you'll feel saying well I mean fire suit
when I got in the fire suit yeah soon as
he liked the fire suit my wife really
kind of like kind of well I mean she saw
me that they're here we're showing the
video right now because it looks so
kick-ass but when I was in that IndyCar
with with with one of the all-time
greats with Mario I literally tried to
make sure I'm like okay I know I'm on a
GoPro do not look scared
do not look scared at all because I saw
Chris Brockman do it and you looked like
you had the fear of God in it I did it
was away from the wall yeah what did I
have one do we have audio on this we
want to hear oh I was I was lucky now
take a look at him right there like that
guy looks like Jeff thanks for coming on
brother thanks for have you got at any
time and and come back and I say said
and good luck to you with your with your
your relationship with Honda Racing
continuing for more Rich Eisen show
tuned to audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
or download the
doesn't show up